right yeah also very strong chance for
him we're boy is the law SG represented
no matter what we're creating a new
champion today that's happening yes
that's for sure could it be one of these
two right here it could be you total you
total has the best chance of taking both
crowns it's definitely possible you know
he to be honest though at the world
Invitational he didn't show up too
strongly at the world Invitational you
know obviously he was uh he was the big
favorite the one seat because of his
previous play something and everything
like that
now I in this is now this is a new
season there's new changes and yeah this
is this is some of the best play that
we've seen oh you're totally right
you're definitely right with the new
changes not only does everybody have to
get adjusted and everything like that
but obviously you Toto could have taken
that loss to its heart and really really
worked on his issues and I mean he's on
winter side right so there had to have
been something going on in his brain yep
oh yeah representing Korea again Korea
is is kind of like the Side Story of
this tournament it's not that we didn't
know that they existed it's just that
they came in for us and they I mean
winner side there really showed that
they're what they were about yeah
usually when you talk about Soul Calibur
strong regions you talk about America
France and Japan right and but Korea
right here Phil Ferguson for her I hated
started out trying to get the plus
reigns he's negative one there so yeah
he presses right ooh
monument meet the Linda started out
trying to push him back there was a
great tuck on the throw to started oh
wow guaranteed damages attack on the
throw though the real good start from
the core right now if you told us having
a hard time start now but he gets the
poke here trying to move his way before
he gets to cave that's gonna be the
first round real strong start definitely
nobody was doing that he was taken aback
of the superior range of whoa now his
precip rearrange acrylic to try to keep
both lad bay yeah and I mean even when
he was up close he was just kind of only
hitting the fastest but when he knew it
was his turn trying to use the batchford
nice from you Toto to recognize that he
had that option but getting hit by the
Sun stain here what's the mix up the
blocks very good respect to all the
challenge I don't know if he meant to do
that GI though fix oh that's a whip
punish beautiful that's gonna put him a
lot closer but he's still not exactly in
the life leader right now so we're gonna
have to see what happened three three P
might be enough action oh and it killed
unfortunately the C Gillingham was not
enough to save him from that throw one
round a piece right now coming in trying
to use the body big hey Ari
whoa it's a tight they weight to each
other I mean I was crazy rock you
because that was a break attack so you
would have got we played off this
[Music]
his back is to the wall in his car
Thurmond is really gonna pack on right
now
extension thanks to the wall he's gotta
watch out for the mix-up Oh bottom row I
can't get up okay it's a 50-50 no two
parts apiece for both players right now
is your toe toes working on the first
occur I had to spend meter yeah more
than likely probably looking to see you
with punished right now if the lower he
gets in life we're gonna possibly see
the full charge right wrote the fix up
is so good maybe a sole attacker with
punished I don't know I don't know he's
got to be something you Toto is is
definitely I was facing him right now um
absolute balling on this basic oh that
should be seen let's see it oh wow
living on a pig carrot there we go I was
always worried about it's not I was
really I was like madness it's gonna be
like a one pixel damage see damage on
that last ender right yeah okay so you
Toto starting it out I mean okay first
round was really hard for him right you
were talking about the superior spacing
that the courier was busting how he
didn't get to do any of that after the
first week so we you know that that's
just the annotation that we're talking
about from the like from the Evo champ
but what is scary about you Toto to you
know is as a Votto guy right you know
sometimes you're trying to get like a
read on the opponent and just a beat on
what they'll do next when they start
doing stuff like wake up throw you know
in tournament it throws you off a little
bit you start getting real scared of
what they'll do
I mean bubbles always been the very
quirky character Soul Calibur that it's
really really hard to get a read on
anybody playing you have a lot of the
time I mean it's even worse when you
back off and they wake up throw you
that's for sure
okay yes
nice spacing right unfortunately not
gonna be able to whip mothers but at
least he stayed away from it nice step
that was good let's see what we can do
if they break dancing on them good
blocks right there with Chuck at the
mitts and every window is 3 V ice right
there kind of setup he's at the ledge
this could be really scary he's gonna
try and fight okay mixed time the Qura
I'm still kind of scared for him right
now
it was strong the first round for the
Cora and then you Toto came back so I
mean if it's the same old story I mean I
guess we'll have to see that was a nice
good fun yeah very very strong with
punished right there close to the frames
nice time
sometimes you have to disrespect exactly
especially with your faster pulse you
can still attack even what you have some
- like that yeah generally two rays are
kind of the bathroom hooks of the game
so Oh cut septal tomorrow continually
being composed gives the Sun state now
he's at the ledge - you gotta watch the
mix up here nice low I'd like that he
rolls but you Toto was ready for him at
that juncture oh that's good excellent
reactions right there from the core and
putting in an even like total actually
yes believe because the yield
what a nut no no no well I think he was
preying upon the fact that usually in
high-level calibre you see people walk
up in the guard right so he could walk
up low guard and got hit by the three
beyond it yes each other
Hey 3d games work very true to the
hitboxes except for a certain produce on
ttles you know like that oh it's awesome
though super remember that one
everything goodbye
yeah you can't air control that one very
very good wave punished with Nikora
coming right back now this is not
looking like a landscape but I totally
meter check your total my steps all the
current okay for hard to deal with that
50 finish my tone good Lots he's just
trying to create space
I like a stayed away from the wall you
know nice low low got the wallet too
good capitalization right there
technically you're back there on that
for 4k that's right the curl looking
really good here if you can just find a
way to close it out you total ice
keeping the wall again all a big damage
here we go let's see it I think that's
enough I think so too but I hate calling
it sometime no it's like it's so weird
without the last hit hits right okay so
2 T 2 and rounds right now so your total
is on set point trying to make it the
winners finals right now 3 meter for the
Kuro so ties you might feel honestly yes
good call mix of time peace each soul
did cautious after his post knock
downtown nice ok another post knockdown
mix again he kept it safe
I guess he's probably watching off the
wakeup CEO right photo cuz impactor and
it's my 12 so 12 frames generally among
the fastest
utano the entire time he was trying to
code the Qura if they're coming at him
doing no hold on wait nothing it's not
online a little more nice block the Qura
not giving up oh wow okay so truck
charge all I can do is this right before
so he went for the sole charge pain
attack right because if it hits it
doesn't grip as damage otherwise you
would have some pretty good frame
advantage right afterwards but it's
really slow and startup and you Toto is
ready for that immediately the second he
saw anything anything at all excellent
play from you total right there showing
us why he is devil